welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the second spider-man far from
home trailer has just dropped and it
contains a hell of a lot of new
information in the wake of avengers
endgame throughout this video i'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the trailer as well as my
theory on how the movie will introduce
the spider verse into the MCU though the
spoiler ban has officially lifted on
avengers endgame that doesn't mean I
won't be given a huge spoiler alert on
the movie so if you haven't seen the
latest MCU release and don't want
anything ruined then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
hope you enjoy the video now sit back
relax and let's get into my trailer
breakdown of spider-man far from home
okay so the biggest thing to take from
the trailer is that this is a post snap
MCU Peter Parker and the rest of his
class have been part of the vanished for
the past five years and only managed to
return due to the actions of Tony Stark
who unfortunately died at the end of
endgame this definitely hangs heavily
over Peters head who seems to be
questioning his life as your local web
head after losing his mentor he's sort
of the new Iron Man even going so far to
where the iron spider suit and being
appointed by happy as the rightful
successor however it's clear from this
trailer that Peter doesn't really seem
ready for it and is ignoring Nick Fury's
calls hoping that he doesn't have to
deal with the trouble that comes with it
of course we know from the prior trailer
and this one that fury catches him
eventually but it shows that Peter may
not be ready for this new responsibility
that comes with his great power see what
I did there in the trailer we see him
team up with Mysterio who we learn is
from another universe and they have to
work together as one Maria Hill is also
back in shield and we see as the
elementals ravage the landscape as Peter
tries to shirk the way on his shoulders
Mysterio seems like the new hero
however we know from various leaks that
the elementals are probably just an
illusion that he had created in order to
gain some fame and fortune I wouldn't
even be surprised if he's lying about
the multiverse and is just using this to
seem more mysterious
however I'll delve into the theory later
if it's fully confirmed mary-jane too
knows that Peter is spider-man which is
pretty funny to me marble is clearly
setting spider-man up as the next Iron
Man and it will be interesting to see if
Peter actually accepts this role or not
okay so the biggest theory that has come
true from speculation is that Mysterio
is actually from the multiverse in both
Doctor Strange and endgame and the
Marvel heroes were given several
warnings about messing with time travel
and Mysterio is clearly a repercussion
of this shield is still fractured and
this is why Nick Fury has brought the
character into the fold however as we
know Mysterio is a big villain and
whilst he initially is seen as an ally
he could be using prime time line as a
way to infiltrate the government as they
will be unaware of its past this is a
clean slate for the character and I
could definitely see him using this new
perception to his advantage the fact
that he is from another timeline also
ties into the title far from home which
is not only a reference to spider-man
traveling through Europe also Mysterio
being in another dimension there have
also been several rumors that in
addition to Mysterio being out of his
own dimension by the end of the film the
webslinger will find himself in an
altered timeline this would open up the
opportunity for Sony to do a live-action
spider-verse film with the movie that
brings in Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield who is said that he would
definitely be willing to return to the
character for those who don't know the
contract that Sony have with Marvel ends
after this film so they are no longer
obligated to connect Tom Hollands
spider-man to the MCU and can use this
to go off into their own direction this
would allow the studio to not only bring
him into the spider-verse franchise but
also into the other films that Sony is
producing based on the character search
is a venom and mobius obviously we will
all see when the film is finally
released in July but till then I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the movie and
if there's anything that I missed or
that you think will happen comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then make sure you check out my
full Avengers playlist which breaks down
and answers all the big questions that
you may have around the film which would
be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]